bonjour est elle alors vous suivez son
rassemblement la diaspora algérienne at
elle a répondu présente exactement amira
la diaspora algérienne se mobilisent
aujourd'hui des manifestants à vous
l'avez dit qu'on ira qu'ils se
rassemblent en soutien à ce mouvement de
contestation populaire née en février
2019 en algérie et qui avait précipité
la démission de bouteflika à deux mois
plus tard alors le 12 juin prochain en
algérie à des élections législatives
anticipées sont organisées des élections
considérées comme une mascarade pour ces
manifestants qui propose de les écouter
chi à la première au 26,4 revendications
du peuple a tiré aujourd'hui sirach
c'est le démantèlement de la junte
militaire nous ne pouvons pas organiser
des élections libres sont le
démantèlement de rage âge puis le terran
mais bon il ya là la police politique la
dissolution de la police politique
c'est une exigence de la révolution nous
ne pouvons pas faire de la politique ne
pouvons pas accéder à notre citoyenneté
sont le démantèlement à la dissolution
de la police politique
on ne peut pas dire qu'il y à un climat
serein pour faire des élections
législatives donc un débat démocratique
émergence des idées concurrence les
idées et ses comptes ya plus de deux
cents 200 personnes en prison ça il faut
le il faut le dire ce contexte n'est pas
du tout un contexte de 2 comme on dire
de compétition démocratique
c'est un pouvoir dictatorial illégitime
il a toujours opéré par les coups d'état
ou les fraudes électorales
donc nous on va pas encore pourquoi
aller participer à ce pseudo jeu
pluraliste qui a été déclenchée depuis
81 88
on a vu que la finit par la mine et la
classe politique démocratique
m à la marge les revendications
démocratiques les droits humains en
algérie
alors plus largement vous l'aurez
compris la diaspora algérienne réclame
ici je cite une transition à
démocratique indépendant du pouvoir en
place est la consécration à d'un état de
droit et de citoyenneté ils réclament
aussi la libération à des prisonniers
politiques sachet a que plus de 200
personnes sont actuellement incarcérés
en algérie pour des faits en lien avec
le irak selon des organisations de
défense des droits de l'homme alors ici
place de l'est république vous allez le
voir sur ces images de didier à mulhouse
des prises de parole sont organisées
initialement une marche en direction de
la place de la bastille imprévus mais
selon elle les organisateurs elle aura
été interdite par la préfecture de
police ce sera donc un rassemblement
statique ici cet après midi
merci aux beaucoup estelle pour toutes
ces précisions